hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about mid-back pain okay so there's
a couple different causes so if we're
looking at someone from the back the
left side of the body the right side of
the body on the right side a lot of
times people have this this right up in
the right shoulder right this area right
through here and sometimes it can come
right up underneath the scapula on the
right side this is all gallbladder and
liver problems okay and it's referring
pain to this area in your back and so I
put a link down in the description box
if you have that what to do for that
situation okay now on the left side of
the body right here this could be the
heart and that it could also be the
pancreas so how do you determine if it's
the heart of the pancreas well if you
have other signs of heart problems
primarily I'm looking at like history of
heart disease the clogged artery you
don't have the chest pain in the front
part or you might have you do a lot of
exercise but you don't sleep that a lot
of times will create a lot of pressure
on the heart but if you don't have any
heart issues okay then I would look to
digestion pancreas again I put a link
down below click the link and I'll show
you what to do if it's the pancreas
pancreas is on the left side gall
bladders on the right and refer pain
back up here but if it's a heart problem
basically there's a lot of nutrition
things that you can do I'll put a link
down there so you can kind of get more
data on what to do but let's see it's
right in the center you have pain right
in the center for some reason the best
way to get rid of mid-back pain is to
actually press on your sternum so what
you want to do is you want to identify
at the level of word is in your back and
draw a line right through the body so
let's put this picture there's an arrow
right through that person's body right
here and it comes out the front let's
say right here on the sternum what you
can do is you can press in massage on
your sternum on the front part to help
the back part it works like magic but
the key is getting at the same level on
the back
that you are in the front so if you're
too high it won't work if you're too low
if you're right on the sweet spot that
is opposing the back pain and you really
rub in that Center you will get rid of
this pain faster than anything I know
now the way the other reason you know
that you're hitting the right spot is
it'll be extremely tender on the front
part so the technique is you work on
opposites now chances are you could have
maybe a cracked a rib a long time ago or
felt like like a good example for myself
I've had injuries to my back I've
wrestled in college I had lots of
injuries with my upper back and I will
press on my Stern on my front part and
knock out that pain just like that but
because I fractured a lot of ribs you
know I have to do it on a periodic basis
because they're scar tissue and things
like that so anyway if you have back
mid-back pain
go ahead apply this and put your
comments below thank you for watching